The Prince and Princess of Wales they
have been visiting Sandringham in
Norfolk to view floor tributes to the
queen
thousands of people turned out to see
the couple
they read the tributes they'd been left
by the estate's Norwich Gates an
estimated 100
000 floor tributes had been left since
the queen passed away Sky's John Sparks
is it Sandringham Forest today job
hi Sarah Jane a really good atmosphere
here in Sandringham it's sort of
neighborly atmosphere very friendly I
wouldn't call it a somber at all or or
sad in any way lots of people who've
come from all over East Anglia to
Sandringham which I think a lot of
people in this part of the country
associate with the royal family and and
people here really appreciative I think
to have the chance to say goodbye to the
queen in their own way many people have
brought floral bouquets some people have
just come here for a walk or they've
brought their mountain bike or they've
brought their pets so there's lots of
different ways to do it and I think
people really appreciative as well that
the prince and princess of Wales came to
visit this afternoon they spent a good
hour here they took lots of time to look
at this great sea of floral bouquets
that has built up around Norwich gate at
the main gate into the estate and then
they spent lots and lots of time as well
speaking to the people who have had come
to see them they spoke to dozens and
dozens of people and I think that was
really really appreciated appreciated
like Sandringham it's got a lot of the
estate has got a lot of qualities that
you would associate with Balmoral as
well it's clearly important to the royal
family it's it's isolated which is why
we're actually speaking to you from the
visitors center because we can't get a
phone signal from from down at the
Norwich gate but it is it's tranquil
it's peaceful there is space here for
the royal family apart from the the
intensity of the public glare so it's
important to them and obviously Prince
William for one has been coming here all
his life important for local people as
well and there were some some really
nice moments when they when they did
their Walkabout in one case there was a
an eight-year-old schoolgirl called
Elizabeth she had a pet Corgi she wanted
to put it with the flowers and um
Princess Catherine allowed her to come
through the bat through the barrier and
do that and then she went back to where
the crowds were and we spoke to her
afterwards and I asked her about the
experience and you know she bursted to
tears it was a really a big day for her
a lot to take in but really touching I
think she and her classmates from Howard
Junior School in King's Lynn really
appreciated the experience and they'll
certainly never forget it I like it's
been it's been a good experience for
people today